this video is brought to you by vid IQ
the Chrome extension designed to help
you get more views in less time with the
none having only just come out many
horror fans are already looking forward
to the next installment in what has
become known as the conjuring universe
in this video I'll be discussing what's
in the pipeline and what could be in the
pipeline in terms of future films right
now at the time this video goes up there
are already three conjuring films being
developed first we've got a third
annabelle movie which will be a sequel
to the conjuring films where Annabelle
is locked up in the room of cursed
objects in the warned home and starts to
interact with the other objects to
create mayhem
however the line that separates the main
line conjuring films from the spin-off
so far is that the conjuring films
feature ed and Lorraine Warren while the
spin-offs do not but with this movie
taking place in the Warren home wouldn't
that make it a mainline conjuring film
here's how I think it'll go down in the
first film at the conjuring we see ed in
the rains daughter Judy sneaked into the
room and she's reprimanded for it
then later on in the movie she wakes up
in the middle of the night to find the
door which has like a hundred locks on
it by the way a jar with the Annabelle
doll missing from its case
[Music]
and then a creepy lady is combing
Annabelle's hair in the rocking chair
and then this happens
but when Edie checks things out
everything is in order
we don't really know what happens to an
about after that because the first two
Annabelle movies are prequels that take
place before the conjuring and we really
only spot Annabelle in the case at the
end of the conjuring 2 so my guess is
that Annabelle 3 will take place while
the Warrens are away on another case
perhaps this takes place at the same
time as the conjuring 3 and the film
will focus on Judi or the nanny who
takes care of her as horse start to take
place around the house with Ed and
Lorraine not there to help Judi may have
to take on this entity on her own she's
also a teenager now so that comes with
its own set of problems and maybe to
defeat the spirit possessing the
Annabelle doll Judi has to have her own
spiritual awakening as a medium after
Annabelle 3 the next movie in the
franchise is the Crooked Man we don't
know anything about this one yet but
like the other initial spin-offs
Annabelle and the nun the tricking man
will most likely be an origin story for
the entity that spooks in the Hodgson
family in the conjuring 2 however it's
not entirely clear if the Crooked Man is
just another form of Alec or if he's his
own entity that valack takes control of
at the end of the conjuring 2 it is the
Crooked Man children's toy that edy puts
into the room of cursed objects which
kind of suggests that it was VALIC but
now that the Crooked Man is getting his
own movie we'll have to see if that
holds true
the last film currently being produced
is the conjuring 3 which will obviously
be based off one of the Warren's
published cases we're not here to talk
about the conjuring 3 we're here to talk
about future spin-offs what might be in
store well in 2016 there was a short
film competition known as the my Annabel
creation contest where filmmakers were
challenged to make their own conjuring
universe film the winner was an entry by
a filmmaker named Julian Terry about a
girl in the hospital undergoing some
kind of a procedure and the demonic
nurse that haunts her no I'm not gonna
show the whole thing because I don't
want anyone getting sued mostly me I
don't want myself getting sued but it
seems to be a likely conclusion that the
nurse will be joining the lineup of bad
guys in the conjuring universe sometime
in the early 2020s later in the
real-life Warren's careers they took on
a couple of disciples Dave Considine in
John Zaffis who went on to have careers
as media personalities excuse-me
demonologists of their own is that this
is actually the nephew of the warren
couple he has his own Museum of
paranormal
objects and you can read about some of
them on his website personally I can see
Simon a supposedly haunted puppet being
the subject of a future conjuring film
given James Wong's affinity for creepy
puppets so much so that his Twitter
handle is at creepy puppet the family
who owned Simon claims their young son
would tell them that the puppet talked
to him and one day the mother walked
into his room to see the puppets mouth
moving on its own
other notable objects that I could see
getting their own movies include a clown
antique that causes extreme discomfort
for those who touch it marionettes that
have been blamed for causing bizarre
dreams mr. sinister an ornament that has
been said to cause unexplainable odors
and quote a very bad tingling feeling an
idol said to be cursed with black magic
mr. Bo Joe a poppet accused of causing
supernatural occurrences in a house and
nightmares involving a life-sized
version of mr. Bo Joe and Island man a
three foot statue said to move around
the owners house on its own
talked to their son and supposedly move
the son from room to room so that leaves
us with a ton of ideas for possible
movies in the conjuring universe let me
know in the comments of which movie
you're looking forward to the most and
which of these other ideas you'd like to
see again a movie of its own and if any
of your creators or if you're uploading
content to YouTube at all you're not
doing it right unless you have vid IQ
vid IQ is the Chrome extension that I
use to blow a video up to 1 million
views last year when I only had about 6
thousand subscribers vid IQ even has a
video on the channel analyzing how I
pulled it off all you have to do is
download the vid IQ extension and you
get a ton of free features like the
video scorecard which shows you how to
optimize the video and get the perfect
SEO score and the new channel audit tool
which looks at your channel and tells
you exactly what videos need work and
how to improve them just go to vid IQ
comm linked in description to get
started and if you're a fan of horror
please remember to like this video and
subscribe to Susie's world for new
Horrors every week bring that death bell
for notifications and I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive